[Music]
so this Pete the Pete that you're
dealing with right now is a wake Pete
you know I mean I feel like a different
person when I'm awake I've put my
personality on I'm coherent you know for
the most part but there's a whole nother
Pete you guys middle of the night Pete
and that guy thinks of some really
random stuff right around 4:00 a.m. I've
always wanted to shine a spotlight on
that Pete middle of the night Pete and I
think we finally found a way to do that
in a segment we call 4:00 a.m. thoughts
I sleep here every night
I don't want to punch someone in the
face but I do want to know what it feels
like to punch someone in the face
[Laughter]
falafels rhymes with awful you really
got to hand it to that sandwich for
still making it why is it called cat
litter before the cat shits in it
if I [ __ ] in it is it Pete litter now
[Laughter]
whenever I'm in a bathroom in a
restaurant and I see a sign that says
employees must wash hands I always read
it as employees must wash hands right
it's not fair that gerbils are the only
ones that get to run through giant tubes
I want to run through giant two loops
and I'm a man
melanoma sounds like a cavewoman but if
you stay in a cave all day you don't get
it that wasn't on the card trying to
sleep if I saw a chicken do the chicken
dance I'd let him eat me
[Applause]
[Music]